earth
the adopted home world of bjork what
are you now the reason we have to talk
about earth tonight
is this president trump revealing his
decision to the country
to the world we're out he says pulling
out of the paris climate accord
i was elected to represent
the citizens of pittsburgh not
paris okay first relax no one for a
second thought that you represented
paris
partly because everyone knows paris is
represented by a smoking french bulldog
who found the first course to be
derivative and zhuzhoun
but it is true this week trump announced
he would pull out of the paris climate
agreement
which is hardly surprising as a title it
is so off-brand for him it might as well
have been called
the globalist cuck surrender or a light
jog yet yeah pulling out of this
is a huge deal and to understand why it
helps to keep in mind one key number and
it's two degrees celsius now
it's a bit of a shorthand but the
concern is that if we fail to limit
temperature rise to that number
things get very bad and potentially
irreversible
scientists say we'll likely see longer
droughts and more intense heat waves
which could cause big disruptions to the
world's food supply
if we don't start with rapid emissions
reductions and substantial emissions
reductions
that will pass a danger point beyond
which the consequences for
many people and countries on earth will
simply become unacceptable
and eventually disastrous it's true and
we are not talking about a fictional
apocalypse like the one in the movie
2012.
we're talking about an actual global
disaster like the movie 2012.
and the serious danger may actually be
more imminent than you think one
estimate says that to have a good chance
of avoiding the
two degree threshold human emissions of
co2 should stay below this level
in total this is our so-called carbon
budget and by the end of last year
we were estimated to already be up to
here
and if current emission trends continue
we would go above that critical line
in about 20 years and that is not a long
time
20 years ago south park was on tv foo
fighters were touring
and paul rudd looked like this what i'm
saying is
20 years ago was basically now
so the paris agreement's central aim was
to try and keep our global temperature
rise
below that two degree threshold and to
do that each signatory would set their
own goals
with a plan to reconvene every five
years to ideally
set more ambitious targets and look it
was not perfect
some critics at the time felt that it
did not go far enough but the key
achievement
was for the very first time getting
virtually the entire world
including china and india to commit to
taking action it was a historic moment
and it was celebrated like this the
moment the world agreed
to tackle climate change
and so the paris agreement was born and
emotions spilled over
so much so that lawrence fabius banged
the gavel again
so i have been asked to bang the gavel
again it's a little gavel but i think it
can do
great things okay
okay listen listen i'll say this if you
are trying to convince people of the
gravity of a moment
maybe don't use such a humiliatingly
shitty gavel
because it just undercuts what you're
trying to say it would not be
appropriate for a judge to conclude a
death penalty case by saying
i hereby sentence you to hang by the
neck until dead
may god have mercy upon your soul
right solemn moment solemn moment for
everybody
so so so why did trump announce that he
would pull out this week well one clue
may have come during his speech on
thursday when he actually talked about
that happy celebration that you just saw
but seem to see something sinister in it
the rest of the world
applauded when we signed the paris
agreement
they went wild they were so happy
for the simple reason that it put
our country the united states of america
which we all love
at a very very big economic disadvantage
what are you talking about they were
happy because they secured a landmark
victory for the future
of the planet you egomaniac
the whole world is not secretly
conspiring
against the united states the only thing
the whole world is secretly conspiring
to do
is convince everyone that there are two
olsen twins there is no way
it is just one girl moving very quickly
backwards and forwards
it's an optical illusion the olsen twins
thing is a massive scam
and the whole world is in on it and the
only thing that i don't quite know yet
is why
but we don't have time to get into it
the point is if the agreement was
a scheme to hurt american businesses you
know who that might be news to
many american businesses because they
were not just in favor of this agreement
they even made a last-ditch attempt to
change trump's mind
25 companies including microsoft and
intel have purchased a full-page ad in
today's new york times arguing
the agreement generates jobs and
economic growth
well come on i mean he was clearly never
going to be convinced by an ad in the
new york times
how was he going to see it if if those
companies really wanted to get his
attention they needed to talk kfc into
putting out a full
bucket ad which he would read on the
toilet
while eating chicken because that at its
core
is who our president but but
it turned out it turned out that rather
than listening to those companies the
president was getting advice from
climate change skeptics
like his epa chief scott pruitt and
human custody hearing steve bannon
although really trump's actions were in
keeping with a long-held skepticism that
he has concerning climate change he has
called it
expensive and a hoax created by
china
and he repeatedly brought that idea up
on the campaign trail
often before losing track of what he was
talking about and performing real-time
word association
china isn't abiding by anything they're
buying all of our call we can't use call
anymore essentially
they're buying our call and they're
using it now when you talk about the
planet
it's so big out there we're here they're
there it's like they're our next-door
neighbor right
in terms of the universe miss universe
by the way made a great deal when i sold
it oh did i get rich
that was a great deal huh you know they
broke my choppers on that
they said he talks about illegal
immigration we're not going to put him
on television first of all the
univision's being sued like crazy you
wouldn't believe it
and nbc i made a great deal with them
just like an amazing deal
why can't you finish a thought why can't
you
finish a thought that is that was
36 seconds touching on at least seven
different topics
including the non-phrase broke my
choppers and yet
he did not conclude a single thought
there
a goldfish would hear that species go
hey hey focus get back to china
you were talking about china what is
wrong with this guy oh god i'm drowning
and look when you combine trump's lack
of attention to detail with his deep
rooted paranoia you get the wildly
misleading reasons that he cited on
thursday
for pulling out of paris for instance he
seemed to think the agreement committed
america to shutting down
coal-fired power plants china will be
allowed to build hundreds of additional
coal plants
so we can't build the plants but they
can
according to this agreement india will
be allowed to double its coal production
by 2020. think of it india can double
their coal production
we're supposed to get rid of ours okay
for the record the agreement doesn't
actually ban america from building coal
plants it doesn't even
contain the word coal each each country
sets its own goals that they can meet
however it wants so that is wrong that's
just wrong
as is the fact that trump said in his
speech america would continue
to be the cleanest and most
environmentally friendly country on
earth
which is objectively untrue because over
history the us has emitted
by far more carbon than any other
country and we still
emit more per person than almost any
other nation so that's like mark
wahlberg
saying he's going to continue to be the
best dentist
on the planet how how are you going to
do that
that's not what you are mark maybe you
could decide to do that one day but
you're definitely not doing it now
then there is trump's concern over the
green climate fund
which finances projects in developing
nations helping them adapt to the
impacts of climate change and reduce
their emissions
watch now as trump describes that fund
the green fund would likely obligate the
united states to commit
potentially tens of billions of dollars
of which the united states has already
handed over
one billion dollars
nobody else is even close okay
okay now to his credit that is actually
an impressive amount of misleading
in very few words in fact here is
everything that he just said
let's break those words down first the
green fund
it's not called the green fund it's
called the green climate fund
i know but still then
would likely obligate the united states
to commit money there is no enforcement
mechanism in the paris agreement the u.s
could just easily refuse to pay the bill
something donald trump
has a lifetime of practice doing as for
the
potentially tens of billions of dollars
no
we committed three billion dollars you
can't just inflate
three to potentially tens i can't say
that you
have had potentially tens of failed
marriages i can only say
you've had three because you have you
have had three failed marriages and yes
i'm very much
including your current one and and
finally
finally nobody else is even close
to paying more that is just willfully
misleading while we have given
the most so far in sheer dollars we are
one of the richest countries
and one of the top emitters and when you
rank contributions as a fraction of gdp
we are 32nd so trump's description of
the agreement is so
flamboyantly deceptive it would have
been equally accurate for him to say
compliance with the paris agreement
would likely require all ducks to wear
jean shorts
and that it would potentially cost each
and every american citizen
five fish and a dump truck full of
hamsters that would be as true as what
he just
said and even
even when he tried to strike a
reassuring tone he got
it wrong so we're getting out
but we will start to negotiate and we
will see if we can make a deal that's
fair
and if we can that's great and if we
can't that's fine
except no it is not fine is it
because the leaders of germany france
and italy said in a statement
we firmly believe that the paris
agreement cannot be renegotiated
and i would not test europe's leaders
when it comes to pulling out of a major
international agreement
britain is trying that right
now with brexit and maybe you can send
your demands to the same email address
that you're upset up for that
it's lick.ournuts at go
yourselves.eu
so drop them a line drop them a line
they'll answer
but but i have saved trump's most
ludicrous misunderstanding of the
agreement for last because for a man who
cites the agreement
strict onerous and draconian terms what
he does not seem to comprehend
is each nation sets its own goals
remember
and more importantly the whole thing is
voluntary
the agreement as a whole is not legally
binding and doesn't penalize nations who
fail to meet their commitments
but it does include a process designed
to shame them into compliance
it's true the only penalty was shame and
unfortunately
this president is completely immune to
the very concept of that
if they even tried to shame him into
compliance he could just hold up
this photo of him in a too short
bathroom of what appears to be a child's
bed and say
i posed for that you cannot hurt me
any more than i've already hurt myself
and at this point you may be thinking
well hold on if it's all voluntary
then what is the harm in leaving well
the truth is it's substantial
and let's start with just the harm to
america's standing in the world alone
because trump's decision to lead this
agreement has pissed off almost
everyone this morning german chancellor
angela merkel called it
extremely regrettable canadian prime
minister justin trudeau called it
disheartening
and the vatican went further saying mr
trump's decision
was a disaster for everyone wow
think about that we are getting
talked by the vatican
and not by the nazi pope the cool one
that's worse
that is like getting into a twitter
fight with the dalai lama
he he doesn't snap often but when he
snaps
he snaps hard and look that reputational
harm
can have real costs for businesses
abroad one environmental negotiator who
worked in the george w bush
administration described this decision
as
the worst thing for brand america since
abu ghraib
and that is rough because a bad
association can stick with a brand for a
long time
just ask sexual assault pudding cups
double murder car rentals
or mr touchy's fresh and tasty pedo
sandwiches
and and then then there is the harm to
american workers the very people trump
is claiming to protect
because most of the world now realizes
that in order to reduce
emissions we need to shift to renewable
forms of energy and the more a
government
encourages that the faster it happens
the quicker costs come down and the more
likely
that country is to be at the forefront
of a whole new industry
creating countless jobs in the process
and you know who knows that
china or as trump would say chaina
trump just handed a huge advantage to
them
they've not only cancelled plans to
build more than 100 coal-fired power
plants they're also dramatically
increasing investment elsewhere
china plans to spend more than 360
billion dollars on renewable energy by
2020 which it says will create at least
13 million
new jobs so you know what in a way trump
is fulfilling his campaign promise he
is creating millions of new jobs he's
just doing it for the wrong
country and if you want proof
that the jobs of today and tomorrow
are in renewable energy france's new
president emmanuel macron actually
issued a call this week
to america's workforce to all scientists
engineers entrepreneurs responsible
citizens who were disappointed
by the decision of the president of the
united states
i want to say that
they will find in france the second
homeland
i call on them come and work
here with us i guess what he's saying
there is
be our guest be
our guest put our selfies to the test
tire napkin lounge you know what we
don't have time for this we don't i'm
sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry lumiere i'm sorry mrs potts
i'm sorry cogsworth you gotta go
you gotta go quick this is my fault get
the out of here you little
get out
get out but look the real concern
the real concern the real real concern
here is that america's absence from the
paris agreement could make other
countries less inclined to meet their
commitments and remember
that could quickly become catastrophic
and that
brings us to our final point given that
we cannot afford just to wait four years
to vote trump out of office
what can be done now well for starters
companies need to continue to step up
and to their credit
uh some like walmart and bank of america
have set deadlines to power themselves
completely
with renewable energy and nearly half of
the fortune 500 companies
including philip morris international
have place to reduce their carbon
footprint
in the coming years that is right this
is a story where walmart
bank of america and philip morris end up
being the good guys
which just feels inherently surprising
it's like i just said
great news everyone ebola isis and that
dentist who shot cecil the lion
are going to save the planet for us
thanks guys you're the best
you are the best and look look it is not
just companies stepping up in the wake
of trump's decision multiple governors
have announced their intention to hold
themselves to the paris agreement goals
as have many mayors including notably
the mayor of
pittsburgh you know the city that trump
cited as the reason he was pulling out
of the agreement
their mayor bill peduto was pretty clear
about what he thinks about trump's
decision
pittsburgh is the poster child of
showing why the
paris agreement is good economics for
the united states
and what we did today sets us back
decades
wow that is pleasantly surprising on so
many levels not the least of which is i
had always just assumed that
pittsburgh's mayor
was a heinz ketchup drenched lombardi
trophy so
we're all learning a lot of things
tonight
but what this means is that the onus is
now on politicians at the state and
local level to do what donald trump
cannot be bothered to and unfortunately
that means that you now need to find out
where your mayor
your governor and even your state reps
stand on climate change and first
you'll have to find out who they are but
then
then you will need to find out their
positions and look maybe you'll get
lucky maybe yours is great
or maybe you live in pennsylvania and
you're represented by state senator
scott wagner who has an interesting
theory for what might be causing global
warming
the earth moves closer to the sun every
year
we have more people you know humans have
warm bodies so is
heat coming off we're just going through
a lot of change but i think
we are as a society doing the best we
can
i i don't even know where to begin there
i mean yes the earth does move closer to
the sun every year
but then it moves further away from the
sun because that is what a year
is
our body heat is not warming the planet
and we are clearly not doing the best we
can
because we keep putting idiots like
scott wagner in positions of power
and he is not alone in north carolina
they're considering a bill that would
freeze progress that that state has made
towards renewable energy and one of the
people who would have a vote
on that is state rep larry pittman so
what is larry's nuance take on climate
our climate runs on a cycle
it goes up and it goes down and the lord
designed it that way and the main thing
that causes global warming
is the earth's relationship to a big
ball of gas that's burning out there
that we call the sun
and it is the height of hubris for human
beings to think that we can have any
effect on that
no larry no the height of hubris is not
opposing climate change against god's
will the height of hubris is according
to wikipedia
six foot two and he just pulled us out
of the paris agreement
so if your local reps resemble those
guys in any way you are going
you're gonna need to work to get them
out of office as soon as you can and all
of this
is going to take work attention and
energy and i know that's not easy
but trump may have inadvertently done us
a tiny favor this week because the
problem with climate change is that it's
always felt
so abstract impersonal and far off into
the future and the usual symbols that we
use don't don't do much
to fix or help that it's either a graft
that's difficult to understand
or a sad polar bear on a small piece of
ice
and it's hard to get emotionally fired
up over that i don't even know that bear
he he could be a dick but but finally
finally this week the climate change
movement
may have gotten a symbol to rally around
because apparently it was never quite
enough
for us to motivate ourselves out of love
for this
large gassy orb but maybe just maybe
we can now motivate ourselves to do
something out of our loathing
of this one